>> IN WASHINGTON, D.C. WHEN IT
COMES PRIORITIZING SOCIAL
ISSUES, DEMOCRATS AS ALWAYS HAVE
THE LEAD.
>> WE ARE WORKING ON IDEAS TO
REDUCE INEQUALITY, ADDRESS
POVERTY, ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE,
ADDRESS PRISON REFORM.
>> EXACTLY. SEE, THAT IS YOUR
ISSUE, THAT IS YOUR GUY'S ISSUE.
>> AND THEIR BIGGEST ROADBLOCK
OF ALL, OF COURSE, ARE
REPUBLICANS.
>> WE WANT TO REFORM PRISONS,
TOO MANY NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS
ARE GOING TO PRISON.
>> WAIT, WAIT SO YOU ARE WORKING
ON PRISON REFORM?
>> WE ARE WORKING ON PRISON
REFORM.
>> BUT YOU'RE UM, YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WAIT A SECOND. BILLY BOB
THORNTON AND NIRRA TANDEN
ARE SUPPOSED TO AGREE ON
EVERYTHING.
>> NO WE SHOULD IMPLIMENT IT --
>> I'VE HEARD THIS ONE BEFORE --
LOOK --
>> BUT IT TURNS OUT, KIBBE AND
TANDEN ARE PART OF A NEW
ORGANIZATION IN WASHINGTON
WHOSE SOLE MISSION IS TO, GET
THIS, SOLVE PROBLEMS BY
WORKING TOGETHER.
IT IS ALL PART OF A
COMPLICATED ALGORITHM, STEP ONE,
IDENTIFY A PROBLEM, STEP 2, WORK
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
STEP 3, UH, YEAH.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT.
>>A HUGE EXPANSION OF
MASS INCARCERATION IS NOT
HELPFUL TO ANYBODY.
>> THE PRISON POPULATION HAS
GONE UP SOME 780 PERCENT IN THE
LAST 20 YEARS, WE ARE SPENDING
$80 BILLION A YEAR, IT IS CRAZY.
>> I AM HAVING A PROBLEM HERE.
OKAY?  YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO LOOK
AT HIM AND SAY, HEY, YOU RACIST
REAGAN FLUFFING REPUBLICAN, YOU
ARE DESTROYING THIS COUNTRY.
THEN YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO LOOK TO
HER AND SAY HEY, GUESS WHAT YOU
HIPPY, LIVE IN THE REAL WORLD
AND YOU SLAP HIM.
THEN YOU START CRYING, YOU'VE
COLLECTED THE TEARS IN A COFFEE
CUP, YOU SPLASH IT IN HER FACE.
THAT'S THE WAY THIS IS SUPPOSED
TO GO.
>> SO WHO ACTUALLY GOT THESE TWO
TOGETHER?  CHRISTINE LEONARD OF
THE COALITION FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
>> IT IS EXCITING.
ONE THING IS NO ONE CAME TO
THE TABLE AND SAID THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY WON'T WORK
ON SO WHAT WE WILL BE WORKING
ON IS SYSTEMIC REFORM, TALKING
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE END UP IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM, TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM WHEN THEY
END UP THERE, THINKING ABOUT HOW
WE CAN BETTER HELP THEM
RETURN TO THEIR COMMUNITIES --
>> TREVOR, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> AND, AND FIND JOBS.
>> SHH, LET HER FINISH.
SORRY. CARRY ON.
>> AND SO ALL OF US ARE REALLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
TRY AND MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> ASK HER A FOLLOW UP QUESTION.
>> UM, WHY DID YOU FEEL IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO --
>> IF YOU SAY UM, IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE NOT SURE.
SO SAY UM IN YOUR HEAD AND THEN
SAY THE QUESTION.
CAUSE IF YOU SAY UM IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU DIDN'T PLAN.
>> THIS IS TREVOR.
>> SORRY.
>> HE'S THE -- HE'S GOING TO
BE WORKING ON THE SHOW.
>> UM SO DEMOCRATS --
>> UM IN YOUR HEAD.
SO DEMOCRATS --
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS ACTUALLY
DOING THIS REALLY WELL
BEFORE YOU WERE HERE.
>> SO DEM -- IT CAN ALWAYS BE
BETTER, THOUGH.
IT CAN ALWAYS BE BETTER.
>> DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ARE
NOW WORKING TOGETHER ON PRISON
REFORM.
>> YES.
WE HAVE ALL COME TOGETHER FOR A
LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS BUT WE
ARE REALLY COMMITTED TO TRYING
--
>> I CAN'T DO THIS --
>> JUST IMAGINE I'M NOT HERE.
IMAGINE I'M A VIEWER.
JUST REMEMBER, UM, IN THE
HEAD. IN THE HEAD.
>> IN THE HEAD. GOT IT.
>> SORRY.
>> I'M SORRY.
YOU WERE SAYING?
CHRISTINE LEONARD WAS ON TO
SOMETHING.
INSTEAD OF THIS AND THIS.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS COULD
WORK TOGETHER.
>> WE HOPE MAYBE THIS WILL
BECOME A TREND.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK? GIVE ME
A HASHTAG.
>> HASHTAG TRANSPARTISAN.
>> THAT MIGHT CONFUSE
PEOPLE.
>> HASHTAG COOPERATION.
>> EXACTLY.
COOPERATE.
IF THEY WOULD JUST (BLEEP)
COOPERATE FOR A SECOND -- WAIT A
MINUTE.
THAT'S IT.
(BLEEP).
COOPERATE.
HASHTAG FUCO -- IT WAS TIME TO
DROP A VIRAL VIDEO AND LET
THE LIKES ROLL IN.
>> IF I COULD HAVE ONE WISH, IT
WOULD BE THIS ONE.
I WISH MY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES WOULD
GET (BLEEP) DONE.
WE THINK IF YOU JUST TRIED YOU
COULD MAKE GET ALONG AND THAT IS
WHY WE ARE LAUNCHING HASHTAG
FUCO WITH THIS SONG.
WON'T YOU (BLEEP)ING COOPERATE?
(BLEEP)ING COOPERATE.
SURE YOU ARE GREEDY,
RACIST, SEXIST, SELFISH AND
CORRUPT, WE KNOW.
CAN YOU BE LIKE PRINCESS ELSA
AND (BLEEP)ING JUST LET IT GO.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS KIND OF CRAZY.
WE KNOW IT IS NOT THE NORM.
BUT IF WE ALL WORK TOGETHER FOR
JUST A WEE BIT OF REFORM.
(BLEEP) COOPERATE!
>> HEAR IT ON FACEBOOK.
LIKE IT ON TWITTER.
RETWEET ME. DOUBLE TAP ME ON
INSTAGRAM.
SWIPE RIGHT ON TINDER. PIN IT TO
MY MEERKAT
AND PLEASE
WRITE YOUR SENATOR.